a cannon shot deflected off the end boards kov
picks up his head and loo POS knock gains speed
as he gains The Zone backand off the strings
Saka to grizzli a one timer boquist flips it
to to the red line Jack Kirk whip around
and Foreman loses his footing sto for a
minute keki closes to the crease and the
cut bounced over the crossbar closes to
beer grizzli to makoy
wco a onetime and makoy wrap around
I love this move here by makoy the
minute that cadro releases
him and bean goes to play
himy now Fant Tilly he's a oneman rush machine and
a leg save by San Fant Tilly had the far Corner
picked chikov cross ice for Mar oh he Dodges the
forward check closes and San breaks down the angle
outside his crease geeki wins the puck battle
one on Three dumps the puck behind the net Adam
BST P clear potra from Lindholm and chov gets it
out of the zone atra delays the entry so it's on
side van Reeves DK do the same for Boston but
he shows more and more what a good playmaker a
can be yep Tessier head hutting you're a check a
glove stop and a stop on Jenner on the rebound by
San makavo to Maran zaka denied by Spencer
Martin what a stop what gets a grass and he
gets his glove on it nice little pump fake
there by Marsha there you SE pass wow that
puck is labeled on its way to the top half of
the net Spen Martin with a glove in a perfect
spot over off to Kent Johnson Jenner goes this way
and that and a close scen save by San denying Kent
Johnson Jenner finds the
seam a brave block by Jake T
brusk Jenner hits the
crossbar Johnson to proov a blocker
stop by by San Columbus has Liv legs
one minute to play in the period can the
Bruins last the final minute Johnson a one
timer a dog pile on the opening face off of the
second period and sway gloves zaka back to lindol
to Bostock a save by Spencer Martin that of kind
of Staggering in order to force Columbus to play
a little more defense forward closes and Martin
gobbles it up hanging on of the puck just the
air too long with that man in that was a good
example right there on MAR coil to De Bros and
back to coil and a marvelous save executed give
and go between Coyle right here gaining the Blue
Line de brus going right back underneath roov
forand by Coy I don't think he thought Martin
was going to get across if he thought he was
coming across that quick that Puck's going to
be right up under the Cross by out to the center
circle grizzli Dees caral grizzli to makoy a
rebound pakra is thwarted bar Martin Patra had
the chance Spencer Martin is having Jenner Dan
forth comes out of the corner redy the wrist shot
blocked and Jenner scores 35 seconds to go another
last minute goal Allowed by the Boston Brooks
the point traffic in front of the net I mean
that low to High game I mean it's pretty simple
and get that quick release get a lane get it to
the front of the net and it's just a nice play
really you get that shot block the puck drops
down but if you get a stick on it first which
they're able to do nice little chop pass over to
Jenna and the offensive binded
forward leads Columbus with five
blocks on the night they have 20 all
told Heen to Maran it deflects pass
Mar this how they scored their goal little
wrist shot not this time heads up play by
shaton Kirk to step into that line of the
shot makes the nice block you attack the
offensive zone wide starts in the middle get
it wide and heining with another really good
play he's playing some good hockey Mason
did not get all of it he got enough of it
he didn't get all of it and maybe it got
a little piece of somebody's stick right
there poso gains the line with speed
gathers the puck back makoy Maran
scores the captain has scored three goals in
a row for the Bruins one in ot to win the game
last night tonight uh it's a great carry in by
posano and zaka and then it's the puck retrieval
and the awareness we talk about moving the puck
quickly to the right people I love the fact that
the Bruins just don't go with one set or two
sets or three sets they have multiple sets on
how interchangeable they can be in the offensive
zone with their creativity their communication
when the pile plays clicking like this we
said it needs to be impactful in a positive
way you'd love to see a power play go have
that killer instinct with this man Advantage
right now ASO accelerates and stops into the
Columbus Zone zaka to marad a natural hatrick
different story last night's gamewinner in
O and he just picked up right where he left
off down one nothing he ties it on a nice
feed from behind and on a onetime on the
offside get down on one knee to get it power
play from the top of the umbrella drag snap
High over the glove and then again a power
play good Puck retrieval good good possession
of the puck they use the bumper in the middle
there he is on the elbow again but he's inside
the dot that's a good angle beautiful shot
over the left P under the glove nothing but
net the natural hatrick greatly improved
but their power play in the third very
huge but they didn't give up much at
all to Columbus when the game was on
the line in the third period until the
final flurry with the two-man advantage